it's culture it's not the technology I
think technology is a to the core
components of our companies we have grow
from 18 people to now 20,000 young
people and we focus a lot on the value
in a mission and making sure the culture
everybody work for helping others
instead of just to make you money
we believe the cocon very different from
the Wall Street we believe custom number
one in pride number to share honam of
customer one employee to share memory
this is my religion it's the custom that
pays the money it's the employees that
drive the innovation I remember the day
before we IPO and a lot of people say
kanaky but the shares we were long-term
shareholders but when the crisis came
these guys wronged by the people of
state custom stay you just watched two
amazing clips from Jack Ma take the next
three minutes and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]